declaration does is it ensures that we
can bring in the right resources now to
help start the recovery process and
support any of the ongoing response
actions that may be needed in these
communities when I spoke to the
president and gave him an update
yesterday on what I was hearing on the
ground he's very clear to me all the
time make sure that the entire Federal
family does whatever they can to support
these communities and that's what we're
here to do so I want to tell the
individuals to start if you are in one
of those four counties if you are in
Carroll Humphreys Monroe or Sharkey you
can contact your insurance company first
line of defense but also begin the
process with FEMA and you can do that by
going to
disasterassistance.gov or you can call
1-800-621-3362 to apply for assistance
you can also use the FEMA app we also
have people on the ground that will be
in FEMA shirts they're called disaster
Survivor assistance teams they'll have
iPads with them they can also assist in
registering you for assistance these are
just the first counties as the governor
said we are going to work with the team
with the State team here to assess
additional counties to see if any more
need to be added to this declaration
um we know that this is going to be a
long-term recovery event and we can see
just where we're standing here that one
of the major issues that we're going to
face is housing and how do we help the
the individuals that have been impacted
by this horrific event I know that our
partners from the American Red Cross are
already on the ground and providing
shelter that those that need it and I
think as you heard the governor say so
many family members extended family
members neighbors helping neighbors are
already supporting some of that initial
temporary Sheltering solutions to help
people stay safe right now but we are
going to continue to work with our state
Partners to find the right solution for
individuals in this community because we
know that every individual has a unique
need every family has a different
situation and so we want to make sure
that we understand what the needs are
and what the best tools are going to be
to come in and support this community as
quickly as possible
I'll give a little bit of an update on
some of the things that we are doing on
the ground right now our Region 4
administrator Gracia check she's here
with me today she has been in constant
communication with the state director as
well as the governor
um since before the incident happened
when we were monitoring the threats of
what was going to happen and our
regional response coordination Center
has been activated being able to support
and send in resources at the state's
request if there were any additional
needs or gaps identified we would have
been able to bring those in and support
as needed
we've sent an incident management
management assistance team they are
right now at the state Emergency
Operations Center they are embedded
there and they will work side by side
with our state Partners to support them
in helping to make sure that the right
Federal resources that are available are
here in supporting these communities
and then yesterday as I mentioned
already I directed our disaster Survivor
assistance teams to come in and start
going door to door into these
communities helping people register for
assistance
well I would say right now is our number
one
concerns is still life safety I think as
you look around here and you look at the
debris I just really encourage everybody
to remain Vigilant stay cautious there
is a lot of Hazards with it within this
debris and unfortunately there's been so
much loss of life which is just
heartbreaking but we often see
additional injuries and additional loss
of life after a disaster because of the
type of hazards that are in this debris
so please listen to your local officials
if there's roads that are closed in
barricades please don't go around them
that means that there's a hazard over
there and as you are going through your
homes and you are looking for your
belongings please take the extra care to
make sure that you're keeping yourself
and your family safe
with that I would just say that FEMA is
here we remain committed to the people
of Mississippi we will be here for you
now we will be here for you next week we
will be here long after these cameras
are gone to make sure that we are
assisting you with all of your recovery
needs Governor you have my commitment
that we will be here throughout the
duration of this recovery effort and so
with that I would now like to turn it
over to Senator wicker for his comments
thank you thank you madam administrator
and we I'm joined with Congressman
Thompson Congressman come on up here and
Senator come on up here well I want us
to stand together
because I I want you to know that this
delegation is shoulder to shoulder for
Mississippi in this regard we got a
letter together of both of our Senators
all four members of the House of
Representatives yesterday afternoon got
it up to the president of the United
States I want to thank the president for
calling each of us individually I want
to thank him for sending a member of his
cabinet here we don't always get cabinet
members but we thank you Mr secretary
and Madam administrator and we are also
in it with you for the Long Haul
we we appreciate mayor Walker and uh and
the state officials that are here the
law enforcement that have come in and we
realize this is going to be a long
process let me say this before I turn it
over to
Senator Hyde Smith and Mr representative
Thompson
we're about to spend some local and
state money on this
we're going to do it in coordination
with one of the best state Emergency
Management teams in the country we're
we're good because we have experience we
we really would prefer if we didn't
quite have as much opportunity to show
how good we are but the governor has put
a good team together and we've been
visiting with them uh yesterday and
today
uh Madam administrator and Mr secretary
we're going to spend some money
we're going to get the best guidance we
can from Jackson and Washington D.C
we want cooperation when we ask for
reimbursement we've had problems in the
past I don't anticipate any problems in
the future because we're going to work
with you we're going to spend the money
the right way according to the statute
and and we want a smooth transition of
the of those funds I've too am impressed
with the spirit
of can do
there's no victimhood in this community
today and uh we're there with you we'll
be back again and we're with you for the
Long Haul Senator Hyde Smith
thank you Senator wicker and uh
I tell you when I got the text Friday
night and Saturday morning started
coming to my phone I knew it was bad but
until I got here yesterday it is
Indescribable until you see this it is
our job to step up right now we were
over at the Napa Autos parts store we
got in a circle and we prayed and that
is certainly what we need
this morning early on national news I
saw a gentleman talking about being in
one of the houses and he said after the
storm it got quiet but I heard children
crying I'm so concerned about the mental
welfare of these children of these
adults Way Beyond this storm
you know I have a staffer previous
staffer his name is Gibson Clark and
when anybody in Washington DC said where
are you from he said Rolling Fork
Mississippi and they would look at him
so strange like Rolling Fork
this storm has put Rolling Fork on the
map we have other areas we have four
counties that have damage but this has
truly highlighted this community but
I've got news for you this community is
going to come back this community is
going to come back strong
we are here to help you
we are here to provide the services we
want you to have the debris removal to
be able to relocate to be able to
restructure your lives but you're going
to come back and I don't want anyone to
give up on that hope because the folks
behind me this Administration this
secretary this director of FEMA we are
going to be here for you we're going to
do it every day do we get people in a
position that's livable again thank you
for being here thank you for putting
this word out I do ask for your prayers
and I want you to be conscious of the
mental effect that this is going to have
on these residents and any help we can
reach out with with any of that please
let us know what that is thank you
Congressman Thompson
thank you very much uh let me first
thank uh the Biden Administration for a
record approval of a disaster
declaration I've represented this area
uh for quite a while and I've never seen
a disaster declaration turn around in
this kind of time so I'm excited I thank
the governor for making the requests in
a timely manner I think all other state
and local Partners who got us to this
point
I want to thank supervisor Smith and
supervisor Smith from Sharkey County I
want to thank mayor walker uh for always
being there uh in this time of need I
want to thank secretary mayorkas
administrator Creswell and their teams
for demonstrating that this
Administration cares because they're
here today uh as the senator said
most of the time they'll send somebody
not so high up but I think this
demonstrates uh the seriousness about
the effort and we appreciate it the
other notion behind this declaration
is they approved normally when state and
local resources have been overrun and so
now that those resources have been
documented not to be here at the state
or local level uh it's your federal
government
that will backfill the need in this
community
we don't want anyone who's impacted to
make a decision to leave because they
didn't get made whole again we have that
process we have to
documented over time
but our goal is to have this community
as close to what it was uh before Friday
night occurred but it will require
cooperation on the part of everyone and
again let me thank all of the partners
who've been here from day one uh and
everyone has a story but all the stories
so far are positive because everyone
who's shown up so far is here to help
apart from that let me uh turn the mic
over to me or Eldritch walker uh the
mayor of Rolling Fork Mississippi
thank you congressman
first of all to
secretary
Mr Rector
the governor of the great state of
Mississippi and all the representatives
who are here
from this great state
mayor flags from Vicksburg Mississippi
on behalf of this entire community
first we want to say thank you
we want to thank you for all that you're
doing for
our families here
and making sure that
the city of Roland Fork will come back
bigger and better
than ever before
we want to make sure that
I'll displaced families are taken care
of
that's being done
we want to make sure that there are
priorities for
their personal hygienes and everything
that's needed is in place
this is being taken care of
we're well on our way
to bring in Rolling Fork back
to where it once was and to make it even
better
on behalf of the entire Board of
aldermen
of this city
again we want to thank you
and we want to let you know that without
your help the volunteers we have
volunteers here from as far away as
Arkansas Tennessee Louisiana they're
right here in the city of Rolling Fork
helping us out
and we're thankful
for what everybody is doing
to help us in this devastating time
you know we often we kind of remember
those of us who have
this is a Bible Belt
and we were all taught that a family
that prays together
stays together
this is a family a family of unity a
family of strength and this is what we
need to make this community
come back once again
and lastly
I'm not only just the mayor of this
community
but I've lost personal friends
I'm also the local funeral director
now
I'm having to meet my families
those who have lost loved ones
and help them make it through
this traumatic time
but you know what
I'm a firm believer
that when you do right
right will follow you
and I think that I've been prepared to
take on this task
and I'm going to do it in the name of
the mayor of the city of Rolling Fork
and of the man that I am and I that God
has made me to be
so I want to thank each of you
who are here for all that you have done
and all that you will do in Future Days
thank you so much
thank you mayor
thank you for doing right
thank you for doing right not just in
these times of tragedy but every single
day thank you thank you I'm going to
open it up to questions but before I do
I just want to remind everyone that we
are here enrolling for it
and Rolling Fork is certainly devastated
but this disaster
did not stop
across that road right there
I made stops yesterday with the Humphrey
County sheriff in Silver City and in
Winona and in Amory
and there's damage in Smithfield and
Vaden and a lot of other places
throughout our state
and so while we're all here today
please know
that we also
are thinking about our friends and
Neighbors in those communities and the
resources that the president approved
yesterday after my declaration my
request for a declaration will be
provided in those communities as well
and so we've got a lot of
press here today A lot of national press
here today
and we're here in Rolling four because
as the storm came across the Mississippi
River
the most and the first major damage
occurred right here
but it's not unique to hear
as I walk through those communities
yesterday
I promise you there's a lot of hurting
in other places in our state too and
we're going to keep them in our prayers
as well
and so with that I'm going to open the
Florida questions yes ma'am start back
here
well thank you for the question for
those of you who did not hear it it was
a question regarding the potential for
severe weather that we have in the state
of Mississippi this afternoon
now we have been monitoring that very
very closely
obviously with the visits from our
friends from Washington what we have
found is that the vast majority of the
most severe weather is expected south of
Interstate 55
we are monitoring it very closely we we
have our state Emergency Operations
Center we were there earlier today we do
have Mima personnel there watching and
prepared to dispatch whomever needs to
be dispatched in the height of the storm
on Friday evening we had 0-300 search
and rescue Personnel situated throughout
the state
a lot of State assets a lot of local
assets and we are prepared that in the
event that occurs this afternoon we will
be there we will be there Senator wicker
mentioned earlier
um it's unfortunate but we've had to
deal with this
these kind of storms a lot in
Mississippi lately a lot of you may or
may not know I got sworn in in January
of 2020.
in my first 14 months in office we had
14 federally declared disasters we've
got a great team of Emergency Management
professionals not only at the at the
state EOC but a great team at the local
level as well and yes we have been in
communication with them to be prepared
obviously
um South Alabama is also in those lines
for potential severe weather today what
we've seen much like the storm that
occurred here Friday night is in the 24
to 36 hours that are leading up to this
afternoon it appears that the risk
seemed to be getting worse and worse not
better and when you stand here and see
this what feels like a beautiful weather
day in Mississippi Please be aware and
please know if you are south of I-55 in
Mississippi today there are significant
risk we are prepared we obviously have a
lot of assets and a lot of resources
from here to Amery and everywhere in
between but it misses Mississippi we
will have people prepared to go if and
when necessary I'm going to ask the
secretary to come in as well if he would
like or or Dan either one
I would say I would say one quick thing
and then I'll turn it over to the
administrator and that is that people
should listen to their local officials
and heed their warnings and follow their
instructions with respect to what to do
if in fact a severe weather event is
imminent
yeah what I'll add to this is that we
have teams on the ground now with our
Incident Management assistance team
that's embedded at the EOC
um to help support any requests that the
governor and his team may ask I got to
tell you that the First Responders
through this event that just happened
are amazing as they responded out into
these communities the countless lives
that they saved while many of them had
probably damaged to their own homes
very impressive but if there's
additional assistance that's needed
right very capable state if additional
assistance is needed we can quickly and
and we'll support the governor and
whatever his requests are and I just
want to Echo what the secretary said at
the end there know how you're going to
get information know how you're going to
get these alerts because these weather
systems change rapidly and then know
what your actions are going to be so you
can protect yourself and your family
those two pieces of of action right now
are going to be incredibly important as
we know that these storms are Dynamic
and they change quickly thank you
we have mac here as those of you who are
local know is our Emergency Management
director at the State uh Emergency
Operations Center and I just asked him
to make sure that we didn't not cover
everything and he says we're okay so
I'll start over here yes sir
number of homes
well I will tell you that
um
when we woke up yesterday morning we
immediately started doing damage
assessments when we woke up yesterday
morning or when many people woke up a
lot of people around here didn't go to
bed and a lot of people around the state
didn't go to bed but for those who did
wake up at Daybreak yesterday we had 23
confirmed fatalities and we had four
individuals that we knew that were
missing and we had not seen significant
analysis of the Monroe County area yet
because because of course this storm and
what's made it so very dangerous is it
came in the middle of the night and it's
these things are very hard to see when
they come in the middle of the night and
you tend to see more fatalities well
yesterday we increased the number of
fatalities throughout the day from 23 to
25 the four people that were missing in
Sharkey County when I was actually when
I was with the sheriff after I left here
yesterday almost around noon or maybe a
little after they had confirmed they had
found those four individuals all alive
Praise Jesus and so there are still some
possibilities that the the numbers could
go up I'll also tell you we had a
conversation this morning the initial 25
confirmed fatalities the number may come
down one or two or three maybe four and
the reason for that is not that the
fatalities didn't curse just there's
some possibilities that they didn't
occur because of the storm they were for
other more natural causes and so we're
monitoring that it is certainly possible
that the number of fatalities will can
still go up but those search and rescue
assets when you have 300 of them as we
had throughout the state yesterday we do
believe that we have searched in most of
the rubble there's still a lot of damage
out there there's a lot of work to be
done at this point
it's really difficult to rebuild
communities if you don't have power if
you don't have water and those are
things that through the public
assistance that we've been able to
secure from our partners at FEMA we'll
be able to get those up and running an
operational uh very very quickly and so
I can't give you exact numbers at this
time but just know that aside from the
number of people that we have back at
the state EOC monitoring of this weather
in south Mississippi today we also
continue to have assets that are
monitoring and assessing damage and the
easiest thing that we can do is continue
to work with our local people to get
that done
yes sir
yeah I don't have the exact numbers in
front of me I believe that there are 13
in Sharkey county is that right and the
mayor stepped away I believe there's
approximately 13 in Sharkey County I
believe there's approximately four
um uh there's approximately four in
Humphreys County
and I know that there's approximately
three to four up in Monroe County but we
will get you the exact numbers uh after
this is over Mike hasn't written down
some of that we're not uh able to give
out yet notifying uh next of kin but it
will get you the information that we
have when the press conference is over
yes sir
[Music]
well I'll just tell you it's been my
experience in times like this
um
there is no such thing as politics this
doesn't have anything to do with
politics all this has to do with is
helping our friends and our neighbors
and what you see behind me and what
you've seen over the last 36 hours is a
united front in working with the
administration working with the state
officials working with the local
officials you know I was talking to uh
administrator chriswell on the way up
here and and and the way the Stafford
act which is the federal act that
governs these works and has forever and
ever and it's the way it ought to work
which is local National and natural
disasters are State managed locally
executed and federally supported and
that's the reason that the Declaration
was so very important that we got done
yesterday because the federal support is
there and we are executing at the local
level now and we will continue to do so
yes
State lawmaker
yeah well look we you know we we have a
disaster trust fund in Mississippi as I
mentioned earlier this I'm not proud of
this fact but we do deal with natural
disasters regularly uh we we made a
request sometime yesterday of the
um Senator Hobson who was the chairman
of Appropriations that represents part
of this County maybe all of this County
we made a a a request to speaker Gunn
who was up here with Senator Hobson
yesterday to give us approximately five
million dollars to get started we will
have the resources though we are going
to have the resources to do whatever is
necessary to work with our federal
Partners yes sir
State the federal government going to do
Ensure
insurance
well I will tell you that and that's a
that's a great question and and um and I
will tell you I spoke to
um I don't know how many countless
Governors yesterday uh Republican and
Democrat Governors that were reaching
out to help and I had a great
conversation with Governor Bashir
yesterday uh and the lessons learned
from that storm because that one similar
to this you know we've we've had a lot
of tornadoes in Mississippi but but
storms that had such significant damage
from one side of the state all the way
to the other
um obviously we don't see every single
day and so two issues one that you
mentioned and one that's equally as
important number one you can't rebuild
the community if nobody can move back
and in in some communities that have
been damaged what we've seen is that
there are a lot of residences that have
gotten significant damage but you can
probably live in them any of you that
have toured back here behind me know
there aren't very many residences back
here that can be that can be lived in
and so I talked to
um the secretary and the administrator
this morning uh the the two primary
objectives that we have before us is
number one is potential housing both
short-term intermediate term and
long-term potential housing for those
residents because as I mentioned earlier
uh the guy that I was talking to has
said his mom and daddy are living with
him in Greenville but they don't want to
live with him in Greenville they want to
live right here and I get it and so
we've got to make we got to make a um we
got to work hard to make sure that once
we can get the debris cleaned up that we
have opportunities for residents to come
back and live here because if this
community is going to be rebuilt people
got to have a place to live
and the second thing which is critically
important is small business assistance
we always work with the
small business administration on every
single one of these disasters with Mima
and we we are committed to doing it here
to make sure that every Federal asset
and every Federal resource is available
for our small businesses here in this
area but really throughout the state
because there's a lot of a lot of damage
I see no other questions I just want to
again thank every single one of you for
being here thank all of our partners
from the state and federal government
um thank you for being here and God
bless okay thank y'all
thank you
I'm just going to move this over a
little bit real quick